why is it that we always have to be a
dreamer when it comes down to peace
what's so difficult about peace
to have a peaceful society
you want me to answer that
i know i know you have to answer right
why is it so difficult
i
to have a peaceful society
the
because it's unnatural
the natural the natural condition of
of men is to fight
and
to stop them fighting you need something
it doesn't happen without pay attention
rob is shocked
yeah
no you can uh you can you can see it
it's not just the
uh
war is the natural condition peace is
the unnatural condition peace requires
effort requires a constant work
the
um
and i tell you the the thing that's on
my mind in the last couple of days
because you couldn't switch on the radio
in britain for the last two weeks
without hearing about scotland
and the separation had it happened
would have been a fight
because the people in london the people
in england
would have had no interest they would
not have been elected to look after the
interests of people in scotland
there in the end their mandate would
have been to take every penny they could
have from scotland and the people in
scotland would not have been elected to
uh be nice to the people of england they
would be elected to do everything they
could to screw the english
so uh
so that's why i
thank heavens that 55 of the population
uh said the right thing because once you
institutions which bring people together
are a precious legacy and once you
destroy them
the natural instinct is to fight
is this the general view around the
table or is there a little bit more
optimism
which i wanted to create
look
i think every time you have
um
the successful maintenance of peace
in this degree i would be in
i'd agree with robert it's an enormous
victory
uh and it's important always to remember
why it matters we just had
two musicians
with very few words
reminding us what
peace feels like
and why you want it
and it's an important testament to the
immense
power of music to remind us of that
there's a sense increasingly in western
europe and in north america that it's
futile
to intervene in other people's conflicts
and futile to try to stop them
and it's worth remembering places where
preventive deployments for example just
to choose one example
macedonia did not explode and was not
sucked into the balkan vortex simply
because of preventive deployment by
united states marines believe me my
solution to the world's problems is not
the preventive deployment of marines
everywhere i'm just saying
every time we stop war from happening we
win an important victory
most of all for our own belief in
the sense that there is an independent
world
and that we have responsibilities to an
independent world futility the sense
that it's hopeless the sense that they
will fight
and there's nothing we can do seems to
me
much more of a problem than imagining
peace it's actually a easy to imagine
peace and we just did it for an hour
we can think of war
as the expression
of the
excess of fear and greed that is at the
core of the human being and a driver of
civilization i mean we seem to be in a
continuous effort i mean throughout
history at trying to manage that excess
and create the structures in order to
have
that management be the state of affairs
but i agree meaning throughout history
we have not done that we have not done
that for many reasons some of which are
structural which is basically that when
there is a serious imbalance in material
facts
it is difficult to convince that the
state of affairs
has to be driven towards
basically further balance but another
reason which is which i think is very
important is that we have yet to
establish a permanent system of
universal values
we are still living in the illusion that
we developed over the past two centuries
that there's an agreement about the
underlying values and therefore to talk
about values we're talking about a
framework of reference that everyone is
is
can can refer to and benefit from while
as a matter of fact i think we are at
the point where we might have lost the
we do have peace in europe already for
70 years
that's not the case in the part of the
world the three of you are at least
affiliated to lilau
connection to the middle east at this
moment
what is it that the middle east can
learn from europe
it's clear that you yugoslavia for you
is not europe
i think that this was actually
what changeable is in a way is the
nature of war not the nature of peace
most of the wars are civil wars
with intervention sometimes with the
help of outsiders but the main reality
of wars is civil wars
now civil wars
take on average
six years now it's even
higher between between states it's three
months on average
and the in the bitterness
and the bitterness and the cruelty
and the narcissism of minor differences
in civil wars the intensity of it is is
much is enormous
because
everything is at stake in a civil war is
who we are
how we define ourself
everything is at stake
and therefore the the main worry should
be civil wars
rather than the old talk
about uh
administrating the world at large and
talking about
talking in in grand terms about wars and
about peace is like
it's the philosophical disease of
talking about nothing in particular
you wrote this book on compromise which
became a very influential book on
compromises and rotten compromises
in which you argue that to establish
peace
you do not necessarily need justice
peace and justice are not
is not fish and chips they are not
necessarily complementary
commodities they can be intentioned
and the tension between peace and
justice is the
and sometimes you have to compromise on
justice in order to get peace and peace
i think should in most cases get
priority that was the claim but it
didn't say that you shouldn't address
all the worries the point is that you
cannot solve all of them because there
is an inherent tension
between peace and justice
in many places you cannot if you want
really
justice
to prevail in the strong sense in many
cases it means
an ongoing conflict because you won't
satisfy the demands of justice that the
parties perceive
part of why
peace is an ambiguous good and part of
why people fight
is that people don't just want peace
they want justice all the way
the the difficulty about conflict is
that it's connected to the deepest
most urgent values we have and people
will not trade justice for peace people
choose war not for irrational reasons or
because they can't see the virtues of
peace but because things matter much
more to them than peace justice matters
more to them than peace retribution
matters more than peace vengeance
matters more than peace and these are
deep human realities if hassan is right
that the only way out out of civil wars
is to rediscover what our universal
values are
then what to do
in order to be able to converse in order
to be able to talk with the other we
have to accept the notion that we do not
have a common frame of reference by
necessity we seem to have over the past
two centuries in particular through the
creation of an international order
convinced ourselves that it is there
it's implicit there and i think that
what what has happened the description
about the change of the nature of war
first to civil and then beyond civil to
non-state actors who actually are
engaged in war with full states al qaeda
a tiny bunch is engaged in a global war
so that change has not been uh mirrored
by a change in our understanding of a
framework of a framework of an
international network both at the legal
from a legal point of view but also from
from a philosophical ethical moral point
of view
i was amazed that you said rob that
europe's been at peace for 70 years
i think one of the issues it's not
merely that war has changed but our
sense of what peace has changed
the proposition that we haven't we've
been at peace in europe for 70 years
misses
yugoslavia but it also misses you know
i don't want to get heavy about this but
you know there are at least two people
who should be in this audience this
afternoon and are not here because of
july 17th
and
every person in this country of all
countries is now aware that
the distance between zones of safety
where there's supposedly peace and zones
of danger can collapse
at 30 000 feet in one instant i i don't
want to overdo that because it's just so
obvious and the second thing is that
every time you go through chipotle
airport you're in a security zone
and we're now used to a security zones
in which
little by little these zones of safety
that we live in have transferred to
governments
powers that used to only be transferred
to governments in wartime
the third element of this changing face
of of
of our experience of of of war is that
it's
all what the
i'm going to say this wrong and leela
chefs here so she will shout out the
right way to pronounce it masquerofka
in which war is masked
i mean putin is engaged in territorial
invasion of a european state and says
i'm doing no such thing
there's no war in eastern ukraine or i'm
protecting
populations in eastern ukraine so we
live in a world in which we are being
lied to about war in which war comes to
us in an instant when we're flying in an
airplane and in which we've over the
last 15 years become a state that is
transferred to
civil liberal democracies powers that
only used to be exerted in wartime so
the sense that
peace and war have begun to change their
shape and
and and why does that matter it means
that if you have to rouse a european
public or a canadian public or a north
american public to face a threat in
eastern ukraine
you have an enormous difficulty
convincing people that they're actually
in fact at war
it makes the politics of mobilizing firm
decisive action extremely difficult
because
we're at peace
we're not we're not in danger and in
fact in a molecular way
we don't live in peace
and and and we should sense an integral
feeling of threat with what's happening
in eastern ukraine but do not
because of what i would call
this general maskirovka of the nature of
war itself
i think that something did happen in the
18th century in old europe
i
one of our most our most prominent
living philosopher in iran is a man
called daryush shaygan and he wrote a
book in french called la lumiere viendo
l'occidon which means enlightenment
comes from the occident the west he was
being a slightly bit provocative of
course
but but i think we keep on forgetting
that something happened in the 18th
century in europe there was a definition
and an idea of man and this idea of man
this definition created was the flower
the burgeon of democracy and the way we
still think of the body politic today
and i as a person of younger generation
i keep on want to go back to that idea
of man i want to try and extract us from
this from the state of exception from
relativism that says well we can do that
because in the end our values are
greater than you know we have different
values and maybe we don't understand
each other and we must change the
barometer of values i think the real
challenge today for peace is to is to
believe in a universal value and i do
and i think that's the connection that
we're here to make today between a
universal value created somewhere in
europe in the 18th century and the nexus
with culture with the imagination with
something that we as private citizens
but also as as writers as actors as
musicians as politicians we may work
towards every day and every moment
alphyshai do you think that's possible
to go back to the 18th century
no there is
nothing wrong with cosmopolitics but
there is no politics to cosmopolitics
explain namely there are no institutions
that really can govern the world
as such
and therefore the i mean it's still an
international world
are
states and it is going to be the states
are there to stay for a long time
and actually
the reason why people are here so
worried about ukraine
is in order to
keep the lines intact
no matter whether there are russians in
east
ukraine or not whether they speak
russian in east ukraine people think
that what
blurring the lines is dangerous
and even sex because lines should be
sort of sacred because people are afraid
of challenging
the nature of internationalists so
cosmopolitanism
is obviously a noble
and noble emotion but just emitting the
right emotions won't do the trick here
because it's still
the boundaries are still there
and the main problem as i said is that
within those boundaries you'll have
civil war
but i i think the question that avishai
is putting on the table is what is the
politics of peace what is a realistic
how do we get beyond john lennon singing
songs
um and and
that's right because the politics of
peace are always particular there is no
general theory of peace that's going to
bring peace you have to solve each
problem one by one
and on the whole i i'm not sure i agree
with what you said earlier michael
because
of course everybody wants justice and of
course what they mean by justice is
always different but they will never get
it through war because once the wars
begin the injustices multiply and the
bitterness is multiplied so the first
thing is not to begin
and that's why whatever you do even with
even with ukraine at the moment where
there is a war going on and it's not a
civil war uh
even there
uh we should go slowly because every
step you take takes you a little bit
deeper into a conflict and the
once it begins it's
much more difficult to finish it so
let's move slowly let's threaten let's
be ready to act but actually acting one
should be really cautious about that
when one thinks about a politics of
peace in this situation
i guess
what i'd say first of all is that it's
really important to strip away the
illusions that we have about living in
peace over 70 years and realize the
sense in which there there is a threat
an ongoing threat to
the post-war order that is a border has
been altered by force so
the the first element of a politics of
peace is simple realism that is simply
facing facts
and the facts are that a border
has been changed without the consent
of the people who live in it and
the second illusion that is even more
deeply embedded
and is an obstacle to a politics of
peace
was some idea about globalization
meaning convergence there was some idea
after 1989 that we would because of
international trade globalization
because we all use the same gadgets
because we're all in the same
information space and because there's a
rising middle class everywhere
everybody's benefiting all boats are
rising there's a general convergence and
that creates the economics of peace well
the i think one of the things that the
ukraine story is telling us is that
globalization produced a good deal of
economic convergent convergence in the
sense that russia and china look like
some kind of capitalist society state
capitalist authority
but of political convergence there has
been none
and also to be you know just to pick a
fight for no i teach human rights for a
living that's what i do and i teach it
to students from 80 countries the only
way i can teach human rights that is the
vindication of the 18th century values
you're holding there is by understanding
it's a bloody argument from dawn to dusk
they simply don't agree
about the terms of universal
universalism and i actually think that
people who have rather common views
about universal values can fight each
other to the death and that's a reality
we need to understand as well
unfortunately is the eu the civilizing
global force which can spread global
peace
it would be nice if this was true
i think the answer to that is not yet
two reasons first of all the first thing
to understand uh
you talked a lot about america so maybe
we shouldn't talk just about america
this afternoon but um
if you want
an answer to the question about the 70
years of peace in western europe because
there was not peace in eastern europe
there were massacres in poland there
were people killed in hungary uh i guess
it was not great in romania either no
the
uh but in western europe and yugoslavia
was temporarily absent from that and
happily is returning now as many other
places are
but in western europe we had 70 years at
peace and
if you want to know the reason why the
answer was america
um
it was not just the marshall plan uh
actually the european union was as much
an american creation as a franco-german
creation they couldn't have uh it
wouldn't have happened uh without
america specifically without dean
atchison and many other people
um it needed american backing
and uh the contribution of nato to peace
in europe is not just that it maybe kept
the soviets out but it produced the
transparency in military affairs that
we've never had before
it meant that
normally germany
facing on the one side russia needs to
have a gigantic army in case it needs to
deal with both russia and tran and
france together
um nato made that unnecessary
um
nato dealt with the problem of the
middle position
it produced transparency in military
affairs across europe it produced
military cooperation rather than
competition this together with the
european union
was
none of this would have happened without
the usa so
for that 70 years piece
we have above all to thank the united
states now
i think this era is
coming to an end not because the usa is
is leaving
um but because uh the focus in the usa
is shifting to asia
um
uh the us is inclination between to
some would say happily to invade the
middle east is less than it was before
and we have a lot of problems in our
neighborhood we europeans of which
ukraine is high on the list but if you
look at north africa the sahel what lies
behind it in countries like nigeria we
have a lot of problems which most of
them are too small for america we were
lucky with the soviet union because this
was a global scale problem and the u.s
felt
it was a problem for the usa and the
problems that europe now faces are
regional problems much more than global
problems and america i'm sure will help
but i think europe is going to have to
do more
to pick up something avishai said
earlier about the enormous explosion of
inter-state war the decline of in
war between states and the increase of
war within states it's it's the form
it's the phenomenon of post-imperial
state formation and we're not
finished the arab-israeli conflict in
some sense could be seen as
post-imperial state formation
and it's going on we now in 1945 had
what was it 45 states in the united
nations we now have 195.
for my money that's one of the great
victories for humanity actually
because it means that millions of people
who were ruled by others now
rule themselves
sometimes not so well sometimes with
internal conflict but if you ask what
you want for a world that would be more
peaceful
you want a world of responsible states
responsible and capable sovereigns
who deliver
minimum amounts of political
space
to religious ethnic and other social
minorities i'm not i deliberately said
not democracy i mean if they get
democracy that be true but just enough
space so that minorities don't feel
crushed and don't feel they have to take
up arms
a world of responsible sovereign states
in a post-imperial world
seems to me a good thing i think it's a
matter of rejoicing that china is not
the cowed
um humiliated power that it was in 1900
and is no longer under the insane
communist tyranny of mao
i i look around a world at which
you know african nations are growing
incredibly strongly and countries like
ghana are having democratic successions
that are peaceful
um i look at
what was evoked this morning by paul
wolfowitz a south korea that in 1954
there wasn't a person in this room who
would think they would have consolidated
peace and democracy next door to a
certifiable lunatic but they've done so
i mean three generations i just say that
i just say that
there are many forces actually making
for peace and one of the most basic is
the consolidation of post-imperial state
order
and the rise of a multi
world so then the challenge of peace
becomes how we accept and live with
pluralism i mean how we accept the fact
that they're going to be consolidated in
china and russia stable authoritarian
regimes
that do not buy some of the universals
other countries other regimes that do
not buy the universals
the description of responsible
sovereignty well they're responsible if
they do not make war in other states and
do not
genocide genocidally massacre their own
people my criteria of responsibility is
minimal they don't kill other people and
they don't kill their own right
authoritarian are they predictable well
then the question is to is to have a
global order in which you have
authoritarian regimes that are not a
menace to their neighbors and that's
what is being tested at the moment but
if you get back to the john lennon stuff
and you ask what what would the politics
of that look like it looks to me like
200 plus responsible sovereign states
that do not make war on each other and
do not kill their own people basta and
that's if we could get there that's a
really
good thing and we couldn't possibly have
got there from 1945 because we were in a
an imperial world and so
the life the the world we've lived in
the last 70 years is a better world than
the world that we inherited in the ruins
of 1945.
nobody less than freud is on your side
when he wrote in this letter to einstein
when einstein requested him why war you
know you're the big psychological
genius explained to me and then he
literally writes you know we may rest on
the assurance that whatever makes for
cultural development is also working
against war now this is almost a very
political incorrect view
um
but it relates to what you argue or your
idealism of that
with books with literature
we can make a difference why do you
think that i remember um uh reading in
one of my favorite books which was on
your reading list one of my very
favorite books has been memoirs of
hadrian by ursula and she talks about
the emperor adrian which she whom she
idealizes a bit he was also a bit of a
tyrant
when when somebody disagreed with him
apparently one of his secretary did he
sent off a stone tablet in his head and
killed him um he i think he killed one
of his architects when also he disagreed
with him he was also a tyrant so
nobody's perfect as a jack lemmon would
put it
in in some like it hot one of my
favorite quotes he was an elephant he
was he was an emperor he was an emperor
but he really tried he really really
tried and we and you know he came to a
difficult end in in israel and with the
revolt of barack obama in palestine
israel and he um and so somebody who
really sought to be a pacifier in the
end also in a way failed and perhaps we
are bound to fail but does it matter
because the reason why i like i love
your scenario so much at one point she
says and i have the quote for you but
it's buried in my computer so perhaps
you should all read the book again if
you haven't read it or discover it she
said really and he she puts it in his
mind and and he talks about we have had
so much strife so many wars and and of
course our internal our own private
spaces and private lives are ridden with
our own wars which are malady unrequited
love
old age death and she said and he says
um well but then because
of culture because of those victories
because even of love we have moments of
immortality
and and to me
that's that's why i believe in culture
this is very nice but uh but
i have to admit i have to admit if we
are going to say what we believe in i
believe in politics
because
uh
i don't like them very much at the
moment
i
we seem to be in a kind of
period of uh
of great mediocrity
but maybe it always seems like that
but nevertheless if you're talking about
war and peace if you're talking about
peace
you need to solve problems with people
uh you need to find compromises you need
to talk to people you need to understand
people you need cultural understanding
as well
and empathy all of those things you need
but in the end you also need
persistence in simply looking for
compromises i have a quotation which is
not from uh
which is not from uh um blake blake or
from
or from tolstoy it's actually from
another it's from another russian who
writes at one point uh
uh
we are pulling at
we are pulling at two ends of a rope
and in the middle of the rope
is called a knot
is tied a knot which is called war
and the harder we pull the tighter the
knot becomes and at some point the knot
may become so tight that even those who
have untied it cannot um who've tied it
cannot untie it
now if you want to know the name of the
russian it was nikita khrushchev
and
he's writing a letter to president
kennedy uh in the course of the cuban
missile crisis for me this is a powerful
image
of actually what you need to do to make
peace you need to relax to stop pulling
on the rope to give somebody a chance to
untie the knot
uh if you want the really correct
quotation what he actually says is he
says mr president
you and i
are pulling at a rope
in which you have tied the knot of war
and the person who has tied it may not
be able mr president you to untie it
unless we stop pulling
so for me that's the image of how you
get peace you stop pulling the rope you
start talking
it's all very true but i would like to
add another dimension
and i will quote a story about muhammad
he went to fight some minor fight and
when he was back he said
to one of his friend
well this was the small war
now let's dedicate to the great war and
the great war was the inner war
and the dimension i would like to to add
not bagutilizing what we are
speaking here about
lives death and
peace and war
is that
each of us has an inner dimension and we
all know this kind of inner war
and we try to achieve peace and it was
an
ideal of all ancient philosophies they
wanted to have eggvanimitas the equality
of mind or of soul they wanted to have
ataraxia which is which is being
unpassionate
and
why was that so important because soul
was important the inner dimension of men
and because
the idea was
that
the inner reality is not peace is war
and the sage
must acquire the contrary of what is
natural which is war
and
the contrary to war was the pacification
of mind or of soul
and
of course there is a connection between
what a man
what people are doing
starting from their thoughts
and we believe that having good thoughts
leads to a good life
and to a non-violent life so this
dimension of interior peace it's very
important and if we were in ancient rome
having that discussion rob or in ancient
greek in athens
i think we
would have started with this inner war
i mean when you hear people say i'm a
realist you usually find a delusional
nut
and
and then people just talk and and then
people talk about the inner self and
and then you get another kind of
nuttiness
the issue is
the issue is here not between really
realist and non-realist
the issue is really how to address
seriously
the problem of implementing
peace in places where there is a war
now a great deal of concentration is
about peace agreements
but the main problem is not
disagreements but implementation of
peace
who will who will finance the peace
who will look after the security of the
people after the war
when when the armed forces become gangs
and violent gangs
those are real worries and the main
worries and that's i think what what
worries the european that there are
millions of people on the moves of as
refugees
out of those civil wars
and that's those are really serious
problems to address
before we address our interiority
there is a kind of weary fatalism the
world is going to hell in a hand cart
which is an obstacle to practical
political action and there's a kind of
global thing that we just got to shake
ourselves out of the world the world is
complicated it's not necessarily getting
better but it's changing enormously
since 1944 we need to understand this
the the other point is about partiality
you said partiality and tribal
partiality is inevitable this gets us to
the universe
the
virtue of universal values human rights
for example
i think the thing this to be said in
favor of universal values is the
constant normative discipline on tribal
partiality that's the purpose of it you
never overcome
the fact that you care about your
citizens your family your loved ones
more but the universal values are there
to say wait a minute
you're wearing blinkers and and that it
seems to me is
to the degree that universal values have
a function i think they do have a
political function in making us if if i
can abuse
the privilege of having given the last
word
there have been two things about nexus
there's talk from up here
and some of it been wonderful some of
it's not so wonderful and then there's
been listening from you and i've been
here for 20 years
i just think someone from the up here
ought to thank you for the passionate
intense
listening that you have all done for 20
years thank you
you